hi
you look stunning tonight how you doing
sis i feel great thank you this is good
good stuff we're back on a premiere line
it feels really good i can't believe
though i heard after um i saw the movie
that this is the first time you've ever
got to like perform your music
in a film i made a whole album for a
movie
i mean i did selena years ago which that
was her voice and her music in the movie
but i haven't really done a musical ever
so it was nice to kind of marry those
two things very i see what you did
i see what you did there now you know i
i did feel like i was taking some notes
through the film jennifer and i so many
times i wrote oh i feel like i'm
watching jennifer play jennifer in
different aspects of the movie it is
there's so many similarities to the
characters obviously why they put me and
thought i would be good for this
but um
you know i was able to bring it's not
exactly the same character but there are
a lot of things about the life obviously
she she's a recording artist she's she
has her own businesses she does branding
she's you know had lived her life in the
public eye had some ups and downs in her
relationship anything that i could
relate to obviously wanted to put that
into the film so
it was a good good little meta
experience for me i've heard you say so
many times that you are a hopeless
romantic and you still believe in love
you believe in marriage so like cat you
still believe in all of this absolutely
why wouldn't i
and finally is has been seen the movie
yet you brought your fella with you
tonight he's seen it yeah yeah this is
just a good date night it's a great date
night we're super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time i would be remiss if
i didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big
[Music]